genre jeu alors si vous avez un minimum
carte bleue
[Musique]
oui et
non
vous avez un minimum carte bleue 10
euros
aujourd'hui avec ma carte bancaire je
peux facilement m'acheter cette canette
dans un supermarché mais je ne peux pas
me payer un verre au cas d'une vague est
un café ou un seul paquet de cigarettes
tout ça à cause du minimum carte
bancaire son montant est totalement
aléatoire il varie chez tous les
commerçants
différents
mais c'est parfaitement légal du moment
que ce minimum est affiché alors
pourquoi font-ils ça eh bien on a trouvé
trois raisons
[Musique]
alors le jour
limite on paye la même chose
la première raison c'est pour payer
moins de taxes et c'est vrai qu'il y en
a quand on paye par carte bancaire mais
elles ne sont pas si élevés que ça pour
le commerçant il ya toujours une partie
fixe et il ya aussi une partie qu'il
négocie lui-même avec sa banque le taux
est donc propre à chaque commerçant mais
il se situe en moyenne entre 0,4 et 0,8
pour cent soit pour une dépense de 10
euros par carte entre 4 et 8 centimes de
taxe pour le commerce et puis parfois la
banque peut vous faire un taux pour un
montant précis si vous payez par carte
en deçà de ce montant la taxe pour le
commerçant sera plus élevée avant que
vides on pouvait on accepter la carte
donc assez euros j'ai pas eu le temps de
changer le tableau on a fait ça
rapidement donc la banque a fait des
efforts a dit bon vu la situation on
vous prendra moins de frais sous tel
montant donc nous on a changé et on
s'est adapté et on a mis 10 euros pour
la carte bancaire le minimum
réglementaire
chaque transaction de façon et est axée
donc voilà pourquoi on fixe un panier
pour que ce soit encore intéressante
pour nous et on en perd pas parce que la
finale dans un mois dans - ben c'est
quand même de l'argent de perdus la
deuxième raison c'est pour nous faire
consommer plus nous faire acheter plus
par exemple dans un bar une pointe à 6
euros et un minimum carte bancaire à 10
euros je vais reprendre une pinte la
carte bancaire c'est donc aussi une arme
commerciale et ça même le sénat l'a
remarqué ainsi un jeune désargenté peut
acheter un fruit dans un supermarché
avec sa carte bleue mais il sera
contraint de prendre deux consommations
dans un bar ou deux paquets de
cigarettes dans un bureau de tabac il
est clair que le seul objectif ici est
de pousser à la consommation
enfin la troisième raison c'est de payer
moins d'impôts contrairement à la carte
bancaire l'argent liquide ne laisse pas
de trace on peut donc déclarée -
l'espèce dans le bar ça permet de payer
les extras deux pas de paris non plus à
la comptabilité tout t'as pas les tables
ont du coup tu peux regarder une
expression pourtant depuis de pouvoir
payer certaines choses comme les cafés
parfois les alcools sans que ce soit
déclaré à bord du camion se pratique
souvent
hum ça veut dire contracture s'est payé
la main la main
le groupe gazier qui le pratiquent en
fait oui c'est courant